at that time you know there were a lot
of opportunities waiting for me back in
china because i sort of graduated from a
very good um
school for journalism
so i need to i was about to choose
whether or not i want to take this offer
and then
i thought to myself okay i have nothing
to lose
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to 20-minute leaders meet ifeng
zhu vice president of partnerships at
synergy global
with her rich experience in fortune 500
companies in various business and
communication sectors over the years
yale is an expert in cross-border
branding and marketing strategy market
entry and business development and has
much insight into global corporate
strategy upscaling and communication of
chinese companies before joining synergy
global vial was the director of business
development at heiser israel innovation
center the frontline innovation arm of
haier the largest home appliances group
from china
before hire she was the chief editor at
the times of israel chinese edition
covering news of high-tech and
innovation between china and israel
yale holds degrees of masters of art
international journalism communication
and bachelor of laws international
relations and diplomacy yeah joe welcome
to 20 minute leaders how are you today
i'm doing great thanks for having me
here how are you doing
i'm doing great i'm excited to be
talking to your all the way in china
right now yes and this is going to be a
big part of the story of of what we're
going to be doing here and but you also
have quite a lot of experience in israel
co-founder and vp partnerships at
synergy global and you've had a wealth
of experience other than that but one
thing that really struck my eye is that
you were responsible in part for times
of israel chinese edition correct yes
and and that's very exciting my my
sister also worked in in
in a different magazine but so i have a
huge huge respect for journalism and the
work that you're doing which i know is
incredibly difficult but interesting and
so yeah tell me a little bit about
yourself and over these next 20 minutes
i'd love to sort of follow your life
journey hear about your experiences and
what you've learned okay sure um i would
start with the reason why i came to
israel actually it's a story that i
never thought it's going to happen to me
and it changed my life completely i
was doing my ma in china i studied
journalism and communication
it was a two years program and i
thought to myself okay i'm not in a rush
to you know graduate i want to see the
world so i sign up for the exchange
program from the university um by some
coincidence like i missed the deadline
for submission of the other documents
and what was left to me was among other
countries israel um
i was i was like i was supposed to be a
journalist uh when i graduate so i
thought okay israel sounds like a you
know exotic place you know it appears
all the time on the on the news so maybe
i should be there what if i become
famous and become a war zone journalist
that was really what i thought at the
time so i signed up for yes i signed up
for the exchange program and then i came
to israel i realized okay this is not
the place i thought it would be of
course it's way better i mean like it's
way more dynamic
and
people are friendly and a lot of you
know uh positive vibes over here so
um it really literally blow my mind
and um so i i came on exchange for a
year i also volunteered in the confucius
institute you know a place where
you can learn the chinese culture and
you can talk to chinese and you know
practice your chinese as well
and by some chance i
met with my previous colleague who was
the chief chief of editor in the chinese
edition of the times of israel so we got
to know each other um we talked a lot i
helped her with some articles and so and
so and then at the end of the time i was
as the exchange student
um i received the offer from her she
said that i'm relocating to the states i
need someone to replace me would you
like to join me i was like i was at that
time i was still hesitant because like
i was not sure if i want to develop my
career starting from israel um
and at that time you know there were a
lot of opportunities waiting for me back
in china because i sort of graduated
from a very good um
school for journalism
so i need to i was about to choose
whether or not i want to take this offer
and then um
i thought to myself okay i have nothing
to lose i mean israel is always
a magical place for me i met a lot of
people actually by the way met my
current husband when i in the very first
year of my exchange program um so i
thought okay it's a magical place i want
to stay i have nothing to lose so i
stayed
and i have to say that it's
this one and a half years of of
journalism
uh in the times of israel it's really
like eye-opener for me because i got to
interview a lot of people like the gurus
from startups from the you know
innovation sector and i also had the
honor to um go on the
official visit with the the former prime
minister benjamin netanyahu to china and
for the you know state visit
which is
the
yeah this is once in a lifetime chance i
have to ask you yeah yes
you mentioned to me that
that you actually had an exclusive
interview with benjamin attenbio as part
of this visit
what was that like what was that like
you know doing an interview with the
prime minister of israel at the time
um
i would have to say that the
other security checks frightened me a
little bit in the beginning
it was like i think four or three or
four times of you know security checks
with other stuff but i i felt i felt a
bit more relaxed than everyone else
because i have another colleague
accompanying me he was the journalist in
the english nation so we talked and he
comforted me a little bit and i heard
people talking hebrew which like for me
hebrew is something comforting because
you know hearing it as someone not from
israel is you know fun for me so okay
it's an unique experience i'm i'm i'm
trying i'm living i'm enjoying it so
it's fine um i went into the room um he
was sitting over there alone he was
actually um he had a tiny cold at that
time he had a very low voice so the the
interview was you know a little he was
not quite excited um and but it's fine
like he i got his quote i mean i talked
to him and he's very um i have to say
he's a person with charisma i know there
are a lot of you know political
um controversial controversy about him
but like from a professional perspective
like he's
uh
an excellent politician to be
interviewed so i really enjoyed the
conversation and um
it was mostly like we were not talking
about politics actually it's mostly
about innovation the economy and china
israel business collaboration as the
biggest topic at that time so um
it passed very fast i mean it's like a
15 minutes interview it is very like way
faster than i thought
and i really enjoyed it and i had i had
the honor to have a the picture with him
to have a photo with him
um it's like
like a dream like once in a lifetime
experience i mean i'm sure that also you
know one of the interesting pieces here
is that you know i'm looking at you know
what what it will be like sort of you
know the big moment for a journalist or
you know the equivalent of doing an exit
or an ipo for an entrepreneur perhaps is
as a journalist to having a one-on-one
interview with one of the most important
leaders of the free world right which is
you know the journalism and the highest
level that he can get through so i'm
sure it was it was very very exciting
but you know
your work spans beyond journalism with
synergy global you're actually working
on as vice president of partnerships and
you're working with teams around the
world and in china and israel to to to
develop business plans and and see what
business development is like through the
this is energy uh way right you have a
methodology that you've developed tell
me a little bit about your work and how
you've transferred from journalism to
business development yeah sure i will
start from the reason why i left
journalism um i enjoyed it a lot though
i had some great great achievements uh
in the chinese real field but there are
many
several moments that i feel that okay i
understand a lot i interviewed a lot of
people i heard their insights
and how i can translate it better into
real insights to
other you know entrepreneurs or like
business people because when i'm writing
i'm sort of like
an outsider i'm writing objective like
with without bias or with no um
personal touch but i do feel like there
needs to be some sort of personal touch
when you wanna
let's say spread the knowledge or like
to convey the message especially when
there are like the things between china
and israel at that time though i'm not
really focusing on china and israel at
this moment but at that time china and
israel like the businessmen are super
different like so far it's still
different but like the business culture
is different and i see few people
can translate it well so i find my place
over there i see
my value over there so i thought to
myself okay maybe i should set a step
forward and
try over there
and then i
tracked like i got into
the field of business development in my
previous job in higher which is the
chinese company
and then i started the company of
synergy global which is also i would say
my expertise there is based on my time
in the journalism because it's all about
communication it's all about how i
convey the message how i analyze like
how i'm analyzing the case in the
journalism you know the stories how i
can translate it into a better
way to give value to the clients
and i have to say like in the current
business world nothing is more important
than a communication and b storytelling
and see
um your narrative like how you convey
the message in a way that it's easier to
be accepted
and how you
refine your message in a way that is
easy to be understood
so i it's um it's not only about
business development it's more like
about communication which is also what i
studied back in the journalism back in
the university
so
can you give me an example of how of how
you would be working with a company and
sort of
where your what your role would be
within that work with a company and and
then how you see the value that you
bring with it
okay so um i can take the example of how
um people want like companies want to go
into the chinese market
um or like how chinese want to go to the
western market i see like well let me
let me take the chinese company as a
better example because you know chinese
they think differently like they're more
how to say collectivism oriented
so their narrative is very big i mean
they want to um deliver a dream they
want to sell the dream to the world but
in many cases like especially in the
western world you don't really like yes
it's about dream but it's not only about
the dream the vision that you want to
sell you need to bring something
tangible so often i was
like in most of the cases that i was
dealing with for chinese companies that
want to do rebranding in western world
and have their either logo or their
tagline redesigned
i spent a lot of time
trying to
i don't remember the specific english
word but to
to make the message more concrete
like for example they might say we want
to achieve our global dream
of
of you know a unified global village of
uh e-commerce and everything this is i
don't see any keywords over there i
don't see any attractive keywords over
there
but
so my mission is to transfer the message
into more tangible keywords which is
like to make e-commerce
um in the sector of for example maternal
maternal care or like in this care in
this sector more
tangible so i will put more keywords
over there just to make the message more
clear and this is like
um there's a lot of things to do um
because you don't just put a keyword
over there and then send it out so it
requires a lot of polishing um you know
like learning of the the business
culture like the corporate culture of
the the of the client company
so i um
i have to say this is pretty much like
most of the cases that i deal with but i
found a lot of fun because it's again
learning the story of a company and then
giving them advice of how to improve it
and then helping them execute it either
by creating something like a page of
company brief or
some
content on social media but it's
something concrete that i can deliver
and i really enjoy it to see
things from
abstract like
more abstract perspective to uh concrete
deliverables
and how does that process look for you
that going from abstract to deliverables
is that mainly with the founder is that
by yourself researching online what is
sort of the pro the mental process that
that you would go through
it's more like i'm really um
we're walking through the journey that
the company is going through i'm
learning the story and trying to connect
the dots between
what the company is now
and how it came how it became the
company it is now and it's a global
vision it's more like connecting the
dots and learning um listening to the
stories that they tell and trying to
imagine a picture in my mind what it's
like and what
if me as a client would think of them
when i first come across their uh their
materials so it's more like a lot of
work here a lot of imagining like um
uh creating work inside of my mind
so it's
i think that makes a lot of sense
sorry yeah um and just connected it
makes a lot of sense and yeah you know i
when i
thinking about and i'm trying to imagine
the way that you work and the way that
you work with the companies and
translating their ideas and making them
your own and then doing the ping pongs
how do you find the context switching
between companies
so you're working with multiple
companies at the same time perhaps or
you're switching between
projects
how
how how do you train yourself
to go from one industry and all of a
sudden to another industry from one
founder to another founder
uh
a great question i um
i did have a i did had a tough time in
the beginning to switch to maneuver
between different projects but later i
realized that it's nothing it's not that
happy it's more about the curiosity that
you have to the person or to this group
of people so
i position myself again as a listener
to
enjoy
the the journey that i have you know
listening to them and all the stuff and
just to
like to enjoy it to enjoy the process
and bit by bit you will realize that
like the more you put yourself in a
position
as
a listener or like a co-co
working role can i say that like in this
in this position it will bring more joy
because i'm
moving forward with um i'm sort of
pushing or supporting them so this type
of supporting work like this such a
value um
of my position
really brings me the motivation to go
with them and to you know follow with
their um with their story and with their
narrative
and um i love it yeah take me back
quite a long time before israel before
journalism you know middle school
elementary school in china i believe
what
what is what are you really curious by
what fascinates you in your day-to-day
as a kid
what fascinated me is
different languages i would say
um
and it's something that had like a sort
of a miracle to me because like i think
i did have
the
the things built in me to learn
languages i still remember like when i
was six years old i was listening to the
conversation between my cousin and her
mother you know how to spell this
english word and blah blah i never
studied english at that time but i just
i just speaked out the correct word that
was supposed to say
and everyone was in shock but i didn't
know where it came from and later i
realized like i just have something like
the passion for languages how you decode
the information
in the languages and translating to
another to make sure that both of us
communicate
and um
and i think this is the reason why i
first went to a language university like
the best language university um
and study english and international
relations and by the way they have
hebrew as a major over there um
wow yes so i went there i studied like i
really polished my language ability and
also my the way that i present myself
you know all the speeches and the
hosting
um programs and etc i really found the
passion in it like to present to
translate and to convey the message in a
properly decent way
which i think is also one of the reason
why i chose journalism later on because
being
to report and to present something
in different in various ways is some is
all the time attractive to me
and if you were to look today in your
day-to-day your how you're experiencing
you know your life professionally and
personally where do you really draw the
inspiration from so what really inspires
you
what inspires me is
at the end of the day the value that i
can give i know it sounds very abstract
um but the feedback that i have from the
clients like the epiphany the moments of
the epiphany that they had with the
clique
that i with the hint that i gave them or
with the explanation that i give them
the decoding process that i go through
with them
is really what i enjoyed because i see
that my
effort was translated properly into
concrete action items that they can do
to improve their performance or to
to be beneficial for them
so this is the point like i always want
to want to have to say um
to enhance my ability for like i want to
go on this path for longer because i see
my value and i believe i have more value
in here
i love it and if i would ask anybody
from
your past or present colleagues or any
of the companies you're working with or
anybody that you've interviewed
what what are a few words that would
describe your l
best
or would those be
i
still remember
from my previous job in higher my boss
the ceo of higher israel innovation
center danielle olenski he commented on
me as a team player
which i would say is
a great honor for me because it shows
that i
they feel the care i give and i'm i'm
happy to give
um and besides i think people always say
that they feel comfortable talking with
me
like i heard this sentence from
all the way back to high school up till
now like they
they find it comfortable to talk to me
they like to share with me they like to
hear my opinion and they all the time
find
me picking up the correct keywords over
there and analyze with them and for them
and they do learn something from it
um so
i think this is um also what they think
of me well yeah i can definitely say
that this this is very comfortable for
me to talk to you so i can definitely
continue continue along the same trend
and and i really want to thank you for
taking this time with me and sharing
with me your journey and your stories
which are incredible and
the surprise element and the uncertainty
with some of the decisions about the
bravery to go about them and having the
courage to go and try all these
different industries and and excel at
them and get to these incredible
milestones that
very few people in these industries get
to and
i think that's just inspiring so thank
you very much for spending this time
with me thank you and stay safe and
stealthy thanks you too best of luck to
the program thank you bye thank you